when it went down I had a few other
things go down and then I was definitely
bummed would I be as bummed as I would I
would not be nearly as bummed now but
then I was pretty damn bummed like would
it how it do you remember the feeling of
like you know just waking up every day
was hard was that are you that kind of
guy who gets depressed like I deal with
depression I deal with anxiety where you
sort of like can't get out of bed I'm
I'm a failure is that where your mind
goes uh I remember I had a series a few
things bomb and I definitely I remember
I was having parties at my house a lot
it was me and my buddy Stu St okay yeah
so Stu would come over and he would
bring people and we would hang out I
remember drinking like wine and I was I
remember eating what I remember just not
giving a [__] so I was definitely
self-destructive uh I mean not yeah I
wasn't like I was like let's get back on
the horse but I was like this is I
needed to vegetate so I was just yeah I
was doing whatever I wanted to do and it
wasn't I wasn't destructing myself but I
wasn't exactly being proactive and I did
that for about eight months eight months
I just but like going and gorging on
Sushi coming back going to a club
hanging out all night a lot of six
filling the void yeah a lot of 6 amers
do you know what I'm saying hey there
folks it's Michael Rosen bomb and boy
have I got a huge announcement for you
this has been a long time coming and
it's finally here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael rosenbom is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone um we're bringing
a guest you might remember he's been on
the podcast he's a friend of the show
the one the only Zachary Levi we're
going to catch up on life and mental
health and we're going to have a really
good time with all of you I think you
know that we're going to make it a lot
of fun we're planning a Q&A maybe some
fun games other exclusive stuff you're
only going to get by seeing it live
we're even hosting a VIP meet and greet
for a small number of people before the
show begins grab your tickets mark your
calendars and get ready for the night of
laughs insights and Unforgettable
moments tickets are limited so don't
miss your chance to join us on October
11th at the Regent in Los Angeles get
your tickets now at inside OFW
live.com this is going to be an epic
night so if you're in area come out and
I'll see you there know we've all been
there yeah and it's people don't
realize
how
depressed you can get like I'm always
about going to the next thing but people
don't realize that you give your soul to
something when yeah when it is stopped
it is like you're getting cut off it's
like instant that's like why reviews can
be so brutal you work a year a year and
a half on something and people just
lacerate it with the swipe of a pen and
sometimes they do it because for some
reason they don't like you yeah oh big
time or they're trying to get clicks or
they're trying to be funny it's like I
always tell it man you can't really
judge a man until you walk in his shoes
and it's like our our business is
incredible we are so fortunate yes but
what did we do to get there what have we
given up what have we you know we are
laser like Focus I didn't I don't have
normal relationships I don't have normal
friendships like I don't have hobbies I
don't have like dinner nights you know
what I mean this is what you do this is
yeah there's like what what do You' like
to do for fun where's the there is no
fun my life is my fun like when I'm on
set it's the funnest thing ever but like
to get there is a [__] marathon and
people don't realize that they're like
oh you know what I'm saying so we are
animals and we cannot stop until we keep
going and even Robin Williams brilliant
he's like he's like 80% of our of our
job is getting the job and that's Robin
Williams